third time might be a charm but a fourth
entry is just pushing it when it comes
to some film series
look Terminator 3 rise of the Machines
can't touch the toes of its predecessors
but it at least tries to tell a
follow-up story that many fans had
pondered after the conclusion of
Terminator 2 Judgment Day the critics
agreed with the general consensus being
it wasn't the best film in the franchise
but it was decent hence the 70 critical
approval on Rotten Tomatoes then
Terminator Salvation arrived in 2009 it
boasts an All-Star cast featuring
Christian Bale as John Connor and Sam
Worthington as the cyborg Marcus Wright
the film covers the origin of the T800
and how the Unstoppable Terminator came
to be unfortunately it also has the
distinction of being a Terminator film
without Arnold Schwarzenegger which is
basically the equivalent of a Batman
movie without the Dark Knight fans
weren't exactly thrilled that
Schwarzenegger's likeness was utilized
but he failed to make an actual
appearance here even though this was the
first Terminator film to truly take the
action to the dystopian sci-fi feature
that everyone feared there was a massive
disconnect between this installment the
audience and critics this soft reboot of
the franchise was a Monumental flop
receiving only 33 critical approval on
Rotten Tomatoes and making around 372
million dollars at the box office from a
200 million dollar budget people can say
what they want about the first three
Transformers films but but they were
pure money making over 2.6 billion
dollars at the global box office that
said Die Hard fans of the animated
series and popular toys always wanted
the story to shift away from the human
characters to focus more on the bots in
cybertron's Rich lore when it was clear
that Shia LaBeouf wasn't returning for
Transformers age of Extinction and
trailer showed off the Dinobots in
action the audience had their fingers
crossed that the fourth movie might be
something different in the end
Transformers age of Extinction is
essentially the same formula from before
with new human characters replacing the
previous archetypes the story beats were
the same the slow motion scenes were the
same heck even the love story was the
same if this film was made in 2023 it
would feel as if someone asked Chachi PT
to make a Transformers film in the style
of Michael Bay
despite the cookie cutter approach age
of Extinction made over a billion
dollars at the box office
but it also received the lowest critical
and audience scores on Rotten Tomatoes
until the follow-up the last night
eventually the franchise was rebooted
with 2018's bumblebee that's a whole
other can of worms there's a million
stories I could type Superman 4 the
Quest for Peace is a study of how a
singular film can destroy one of the
most popular franchises in the world
by the time this movie entered
production there wasn't really a demand
for it Superman 3 had seen a drop in its
earnings and critical reception
indicating it might have been a good
time to wrap up the story as the trilogy
however the Kanan group secured the
rights to Superman and convinced
Christopher Reeve to return as the man
of steel for another feature in which he
had story input speaking about working
with Canon to the Los Angeles Times
Reeves said they're like the guy who
flies tourists and wants first class
service I admire the recklessness in
buying into Superman though they do like
to nickel and dime you on paper clips
but for the most part we're getting what
we want famously Superman 4 experienced
a tumultuous production featuring budget
cuts cheap effects and entire scenes of
the movie being trimmed to keep down the
costs Mark pillow who played nuclear man
explained to Yahoo how most of his
scenes were cut and how he had a feeling
all was not well in the end the film was
ravaged by fans and critics sentencing
any potential Superman filmed to The
Phantom Zone for almost two decades Home
Alone 3 had the smarts to change
characters wouldn't realize Macaulay
Culkin took a break from acting and
there was no chance this feature would
lure him out of her environment wasn't
as good as the previous entries in the
film series no but it executes a similar
premise under an original guys and fans
accepted it for what it was the made for
TV Home Alone 4 taking back the house
thought it could capitalize on the
original series popularity in return to
the adventures of Kevin McAllister in
one of his main foes Marv and a new
flick unfortunately it recasts both
roles as Mike Weinberg and French
Stewart replaced Culkin and Daniel Stern
respectively naturally fans were having
none of it and rejected the film out of
principle what is even more insulting is
how Home Alone 4 tries to recreate the
exact same gags from the first two
movies
despite the negative reaction and
general disinterest in this movie it
didn't stop filmmakers from soldiering
on and making further uninspired sequels
keep the change you filthy animal The
Matrix has always been a peculiar
franchise in the sense that everyone
loved the first film but the sequels
weren't as universally beloved upon
release they weren't hated but one would
struggle to find someone who listed The
Matrix Reloaded or The Matrix
Revolutions as their favorite in the
film series nonetheless they stood the
test of time and most fans tend to look
back on them more fondly now since they
wrapped up the story of Neo considering
the conclusive nature of the trilogy
eyebrows were raised when it was
announced the fourth movie had entered
production and would see The Return of
Keanu Reeves and carrion Moss there were
questions but of course fans would tune
in to see what the Matrix resurrections
was all about what followed was one of
the most divisive responses to a matrix
film yet while the critics gave it 63
critical approval on Rotten Tomatoes
audience members were left confused by
what they had seen the film plays like a
meta commentary on the previous films
while it seemingly brings back these
characters for no good reason other than
to continue the story resurrections also
bombed at the box office only making 150
27 million dollars from 190 million
dollar budget that said there's a caveat
in the sense that the world was only
emerging from the coronavirus pandemic's
Haze and Warner Brothers model of
dropping Cinema releases on HBO Max on
the same day didn't help box office
numbers
indisputably Jack Sparrow is the most
iconic character from the Pirates of the
Caribbean movies however the operative
word is Pirates here a large part of the
franchise's success to that point had
come due to the supporting performances
from Will Turner and Elizabeth Swann
while Captain Jack might have been the
main face on the poster and the
character with the best lines will and
Elizabeth were the heartbeat of the
story and brought steadiness to the Wild
Adventures the fourth movie on Stranger
Tides didn't feature either of them in
fact the two actors declined to return
for the movie speaking to the
independent Keira Knightley said I said
when I finished the trilogy that that
was going to be it I had a wonderful
time on it and I met some extraordinary
people but you know I think for me three
is enough definitely while on Stranger
Tides did feature other returning
characters such as Captain Barbosa it
simply lacks the Gusto and appeal of the
previous films the new cast members
didn't possess the chemistry of Will and
Elizabeth and their absence was sorely
felt here
I hate you by the time Shrek III
released DreamWorks was pushing it how
many times can an unfriendly ogre his
talking donkey friend and other fairy
tale characters make us laugh until our
insides hurt well the studio had the
last lap as the movie made over 800
million dollars at the global box office
regardless of what anyone thought of
Shrek and its longevity as a franchise
the families turned up in numbers to
watch the movies as revealed by the
screenwriter the original plan for Shrek
was to end it after five films though
this changed while the team made Shrek
Forever After believing it would end the
series on a more conclusive note while
the fourth movie did introduce new
characters and different ogres it was
clear the series was on its last legs
and stumbling around aimlessly the jokes
and premises are repetitive and the
movie never feels like it will surprise
the audience in a positive way all
things considered it seemed like a wise
choice to end the film series there
however nothing is ever sacred in
Hollywood and there have been talks of
more Shrek films in the future Tim
Burton redefined the possibilities of
comic book movies with the release of
1980 89's Batman he showed how these
superhero films could be more than
kid-friendly fodder however it was the
same Devil May care attitude that
resulted in him getting the sack and
being replaced by Joel Schumacher for
Batman Forever After his dark aesthetic
in Batman Returns failed to sell toys
while it's generally accepted that
Batman Forever isn't as good as its
predecessors the audience has still had
fun with it and it raked in over 330
million dollars at the box office
expectedly Schumacher was given the keys
to the bat cave for the sequel Batman
and Robin the drama began when Val
Kilmer decided he didn't want to be
Batman anymore and a part of the project
leaving the door open for George Clooney
to slip into the cape and cowl however
the biggest issue was not the change in
actors instead it was Studio
interference after the financial success
of Batman Forever the toy companies and
other partners were interested in making
as much merchandise as possible out of
the film this impacted the actual
quality as it feels like one giant
commercial the fans and critics saw
right through it and everyone lambasted
Batman and Robin it also killed any
potential Batman men movies for eight
years this is why Superman works alone
The Karate Kid franchise was built on
the chemistry and friendship of Daniel
Larusso and Mr Miyagi even though Mr
Miyagi is no longer part of the story in
the current ERA due to the passing of
the actor his influenced and invaluable
lessons can be felt in Cobra Kai as well
the first three Karate Kid movies
established and solidified this bot as
Daniel and Mr Miyagi helped each other
in their own unique way then a fourth
film titled The Next Karate Kid arrived
in 1994 without Daniel writing in his
autobiography waxing on the Karate Kid
in Me actor Ralph Macchio revealed he
was never asked to return for the film
in fact he found out the movie was
happening after reading about it in the
paper in The Next Karate Kid Daniel is
replaced by Julie Pierce played by
Hilary Swank as the new lead much like
the story before Mr Miyagi takes Julie
under his wing and teaches her karate
however the audience and critics didn't
exactly take to this change in a
positive manner blasting the derivative
formula while Swank's performance was
praised the film stinks up the franchise
on Rotten Tomatoes with a seven percent
critical approval rating and 24 audience
score instead of releasing X-Men 4 20th
Century Fox chose to focus on a prequel
of the franchise's most popular
character Wolverine the template for the
story was already there in the form of
the comic book mini-series origin all
the film would have to do is lift from
The Source material and adapt it to the
big screen and thrown Wolverine while
X-Men Origins Wolverine takes influence
from the comics it also veers off down a
tangent that didn't leave many viewers
happy for one the decision to make
Sabertooth and Wolverine Brothers feels
too much like a soap opera twist second
Gambit is introduced in the film but he
doesn't play nearly enough of a major
role and finally there's Deadpool by
refusing to give the Merc with a mouth a
costume and stitching his lips shut it
takes away everything that made the
character popular to begin with in the
years since then Brian Reynolds Deadpool
movies have felt fun on how the
character was treated in this adaptation
there had been plans for a Magneto
origin film in the same vein as X-Men
Origins Wolverine however the lukewarm
reception towards the film and average
box office performance or the pin in the
idea what are you doing has an action
horror franchise underworld strikes a
fine balance between the Frights and
thrilling spectacle the third movie Rise
of the likings acts as a prequel and
only features the series lead Kate
Beckinsale and a cameo at the end after
having the missing story blank spelled
fans were excited to see Beckinsale
return in full force as Celine for
2012's underworld Awakening yet all the
excitement frenetic energy and
originality from before had been
depleted by the time the fourth movie
arrived critics give it a shallow 25
approval rating on Rotten Tomatoes and
many were left questioning what was the
point of continuing the story if it was
going to be Bland another sequel
underworld blood Wars dropped in 2016
but even that couldn't give the film
series The Bite it needed to get back on
track to its Glory Days
thank you